Cognitive Behavioral Therapy is based on the idea
that certain situations trigger false core beliefs
that negatively impact our thoughts,
emotions, behavior, and physical reactions.
Once we learn how to identify what situations
bring upon such destructive thoughts,
we can practice developing new interpretations
that will then change our pattern of reaction.
The therapy is widely used to help people with
phobias, depression, anxieties, or addictions.
To show how it works, let's look at Lily,
a teenage girl who hates going to school due
to her fear of being judged and humiliated.
In her first session, the therapist tries to
build trust and explains how CBT functions
since the better Lily understands the process, the
more likely it is that the therapy is effective.
The therapist also illustrates how our
brain, in specific situations, follows
a fixed path of reason — which gets stronger
after years of having the same thought process.
Many of our destructive behaviors are
based on false core beliefs — thoughts
that objectively don't make sense. We
acquired these false beliefs when we
were too young to interpret others
correctly. Throughout the therapy,
Lily will try to unlearn these false beliefs
and create new mental pathways that will
replace the false beliefs she holds of
herself with more realistic thoughts.
Once Lily understands the process,
the counselor begins to ask questions
following the Socratic method, a form
of argumentative conversation that
stimulates critical thinking to draw out
false ideas and underlying assumptions.
“Would you like to tell me why you
are here today?” Starts the therapist.
“Because I think I’m not normal,” Lily responds.
Therapist1: You appear perfectly normal to me,
can you be more specific?
Lily1: I think I’m afraid of people.
Therapist2: So, you are afraid of me?
Lily2: No
Therapist3: Do you feel socially insecure?
Lily3: I’m not sure what you mean.
Therapist4: Tell me how you feel about school.
Lily4: I’m scared of going because they
think I’m stupid.
Throughout the interview, the counselor takes
notes of Lily’s answers and identifies the
signs of social anxiety based on a false
core belief - Lily believes she is stupid.
For homework, Lily should practice introspection.
The goal: to find out which situations trigger her
negative thoughts. She gets a learning
journal to keep record of all triggers
and other observations, such as self-talk or
interpretations of particular events and people.
During the following week, Lily becomes more aware
of her thoughts and the physical reactions they
trigger. By paying attention to her feelings,
she identifies a specific pattern which occurs
every time during math class. The moment her
teacher begins to ask questions her heart
starts racing and her palms get sweaty - she
worries about having to answer the question,
about making a mistake, about looking
dumb in front of all the others.
In her second session, Lily shares her
observations and the therapist helps her
realize that her cognitive-behavioral patterns
are false. First, her math grades are great,
so she should feel anything but stupid.
Second, she explains that there are
always more interpretations to the same thing.
What to her may look like her "stupid" face,
to others she may just look unhappy about having
to answer. The reason she is afraid of what people
think is a form of social anxiety — a completely
irrational cognitive behavioral response.[5.7]
As the sessions continue, the therapist
suggests three practical strategies:
Through Journaling, Lily records her negative
beliefs and reformulates them into positive
ones she can replace them with.
Constructive Self-talk, helps her
to replace a critical voice with a positive one.
And she starts exposure exercises, which means
Lilly deliberately puts herself in situations
where she becomes the center of attention.
Along the way, the two set goals that
are specific, measurable, achievable,
realistic, and time-based. SMART goals
give her control over how she progresses
thus helping her to gain confidence in herself.
Over time and with a lot of practise, her brain
builds new neural pathways that lead to different,
more neutral reactions to the
same old triggers. And one day,
Lily may even enjoy the thrill of speaking
in front of her class. Her interpretation
of the situation is more realistic and
more aligned with those of the others.
CBT was initially developed in 1964 by Aaron
Temkin Beck. Beck hypothesised that people's
feelings are determined by the way they interpret
situations, rather than by the situations per se.
About depression he once said: “If our thinking
is bogged down by distorted symbolic meanings,
illogical reasoning and erroneous interpretations,
we become, in truth, blind and deaf”.
This and all other Sprouts videos
are licensed under creative commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses,
or to start projects — and today, thousands
already do! To learn how it works, and download
this video without ads or background music, check
out our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education,
visit our Patreon — that’s patreon.com/sprouts.